[Music]
we see buildings collapse like cards or
we see them fall down as a block it is
the base of the buildings were not safe
of course many accused the contractors
and we saw some of the contractors
trying to flee the country but the
Justice Ministry established earthquake
investigation commissions under the
chief public prosecutors offices of
those main 10 cities affected by the
earthquake
foreign
[Music]
actors is not a main solution it's it
may be just a scapegoating unless these
investigations and Chase Afters follow
other responsibles like the
municipalities like the inspection
companies Architects engineers and even
the landowners
[Music]